it's quiet on the savannas along the
lower reaches of the Congo River much
too quiet where once large herds came to
drink at watering holes there's now
little sign of life the large African
fauna have disappeared they fell victim
to merciless hunting biologists mannar
unbend a and his colleagues from the WWF
environmental organization are doing
research in this deserted grassland
they're assessing how much biomass and
biodiversity still exist in the Congo
Basin even the smallest signs of life
are important antelope oof prints in the
mud for example each detail is carefully
measured we're doing a kind of inventory
of the fauna here there used to be
animals like elephants and lions so
we're seeing what's still here and what
isn't esky exist esk yana yana data are
also collected from the air an airplane
flies over carefully chosen areas in the
Congo Basin
on board is a lidar system a laser that
scans the ground the data it delivers
can be analyzed to determine the
condition of the forest whether it's
still intact or has been damaged by
clear cutting or grazing the result is a
three-dimensional map that indicates
tree height buildings roads and open
areas those data are then used to
calculate how much carbon dioxide the
region can absorb the Congo Basin is
nearly as large as Western Europe it
will take many months for all the data
to be gathered and analyzed but they
then will be worth money according to
Elvis chaibasa from WWF it's an
important opportunity for the Democratic
Republic of the Congo in regard to
preserving the forest and in preparation
for future trading with co2 certificates
a fake video album the environmentalists
hope that if money from emissions
trading starts to flow in the region
protecting the forest would be worth
more than destroying but it's a long way
until that point is reached and time is
running out in order to provide fuel for
the rapidly growing population large
swaths of forest are turned into
charcoal which is loaded on trucks and
then shipped to cities o rly shapiro
heads the project to assess biomass
along the Congo with the lidar laser
surveying system she says the aircraft
isn't enough the measuring really needs
to be done from space so we're using
satellite imagery to complement the
airborne lidar data to effectively view
the entire country in one image from
space to be able to see all of the force
at once and that view is cause for
concern satellite expert eddie bob
bailey says large parts of the Congo
Basin are still forested but the
rainforest is shrinking to get this map
we process 8,000
images from NASA and we have before
station around big cities where we can
see in Kisangani and we have also
deforestation in the eastern part of
Congo where we had a conflict in the
past war and corruption are the biggest
threats to the forest and there has been
plenty of both in the Congo Basin
meanwhile manama ben de and his WWF team
continue to gather data about the plant
and animal world it's hard work and it's
hot out here you seem to some about law
here we're in the tree savena down on
the river there's riparian forest we're
now going to the forest to collect
further data about the biodiversity the
floor and biomass there the floor aw mas
the counting is done within a precisely
measured area the researchers
extrapolate that data about biomass to
the entire forest this is our
predetermined area in which we examine
the height of the trees their
circumference and the color of the wood
we examine the entire biosphere and then
compare that data with what comes from
the lead are here the forest is still
intact and there's a lot of biomass
that's good for the carbon dioxide
footprint but what the researchers are
not finding is animals this forest is as
empty as the savanna that surrounds it
it's former residence of long since
disappeared to the meat markets of the
cities